i'm gonna get you out all right but we
don't have much time
who are you i'm harry osborn i want to
make you a deal
i should kill you come on
think bigger max i'm not the one you
want
you want spiderman and i can give it to
you
but i need something first
i need you to get me in the odd school
did you win
you own it uh not anymore
ozcorp betrayed us both so i can't get
in there without you
and you can't get out of here without me
what's happening someone pulled an alarm
in the iso unit
you could possibly know what i want you
submitted the design for the grid
and they stole it and now you want it
back you just want to take back what's
yours
now it is all the power in the city max
and it's right at your fingertips
and then once you shut down the crate
spiderman will come to you and i want
you to make it bleed
max we don't have much time go go
go give me one reason why because i need
you
you need me yes i need
you you are my only chance that i have
at surviving you name it yes
i need you i need you please please
please i know what it's like to be
thrown away
so
[Music]
wow
you want to be my friend i thought we
were already friends
i had a friend once it didn't work out
yeah me too then let's go catch a spot
you